Моя порада пану Зеленському - виконувати очікування тих людей, які за нього проголосували.
Так казав в одному з інтерв’ю після перемоги Зеленського на виборах один з лідерів ОПЗЖ Віктор Медведчук.
Чи дослухався до цієї поради президент - невідомо.
Але для багатьох його виборців справжня боротьба з корупцією та
засиллям олігархів в Україні була справді одним з найбільших очікувань.
Тепер Віктора Медведчука підозрюють у державній зраді, а також у діяльності,
що спрямована на підрив економічної безпеки України, а саме
замаху на розкрадання національних ресурсів в анексованому Росією Криму.
Деякі оглядачі пов’язують ці підозри та обшуки в помешканні Медведчука
і його офісі з недавнім візитом у Київ держсекретаря США Ентоні Блінкена,
що начебто є тиск Вашингтона на українську владу, щоб змусити Київ
приборкати олігархів та "п’яту колону" Росії в Україні.
Колишній посол США в Україні Стівен Пайфер не такий категоричний.
Я цього не виключаю, але думаю, що складно уявити, щоб держсекретар Блінкен
казав, щоб позбулися цієї конкретної особи.
Я вважаю, що коли держсекретар був у Києві минулого тижня, він вірогідно зазначив,
що Україні треба щось робити з величезним політичним впливом олігархів.
Але я не думаю, що він називав якісь конкретні прізвища.
Можливо, просто вже настав час діяти й Україні, бо пан Медведчук
під санкціями уряду США ще, гадаю, з 2015 року.
Як росіяни і пан Путін на це відреагують?
Думаю, їм це не сподобається. Але зрештою вони не мають дивуватися.
Якби хтось з олігархів займався якоюсь економічною діяльністю у Росії
і був би настільки тісно пов’язаний з Києвом, як пан Медведчук,
вочевидь, з Кремлем, я думаю, що його вже давно посадили б у Росії.
Віктор Медведчук не лише "сірий кардинал" української політики.
Його поза очі називали "недоторканним" через особливі стосунки з президентом Путіним,
який є його кумом. Тож німецькі соціал-демократи у Європарламенті припускають,
що це може суттєво позначитися на переговорному процесі з Росією.
Я розглядаю це радше як захід, який не сприяє зниженню напруженості
у відносинах з Росією. Я вважаю, що це розкручує спіраль ескалації, яка не сприяє
знаходженню рішення, заснованого на політичному діалозі.
Тому я дивлюся з певним скепсисом на те, що відбувається.
Часто політики роблять ставку на націоналізм, коли втрачають підтримку серед населення.
У мене є побоювання, що це відбувається і в цьому випадку.
Наскільки це узгоджено з адміністрацією Байдена, - на мою думку,
це залишається незрозумілим. Я думаю, що це ініціатива самого Зеленського,
щоб здобути більше підтримки серед населення. Я не хочу брати участі у спекуляціях
щодо його мотивів. Я загалом розглядаю це як розвиток, який не сприяє
тому, щоб спонукати Росію піти на поступки в цьому конфлікті.
Водночас депутат Європарламенту Андрюс Кубілюс вважає справу Медведчука
одним з елементів війни з гібридними загрозами з боку Росії.
Євродепутат не здивований цією підозрою та звинуваченнями проти лідера ОПЗЖ.
Я думаю, те, що міститься у справі проти Медведчука, підписаній генпрокуроркою,
- це серйозний матеріал. І я не здивований, що Кремль намагається використати
різні можливості в Україні, використовуючи Медведчука чи інших,
намагаючись вплинути на російськомовних громадян України.
Це спрямовано проти суверенітету та безпеки України.
Тож держава має захищатися. Не лише проти танків чи артилерії,
але також проти інструментів пропаганди, спрямованих на людські уми та серця.
Держава повинна захищати не лише свою територію, але також уми та серця.
Це те, що українська влада зараз робить.
Тож я можу оцінити це лише позитивно.
Сам же Медведчукзапевняє, що тікати з України не збирається,
і називає ці події політичною розправою. Тепер справа за слідством
та українськими судами, в яких довести звинувачення
проти досвідченого юриста з численними зв’язками буде непросто.